The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this is
an example in SCET one
where the degrees of freedom
in the p plus p minus plane
looked as follows.
So we had hard modes
that lived out here at p
squared in order some
large scale q squared,
then we had collinear
modes for the two jets
that are going to be
going back to back,
and I'll draw the
picture in a second.
Then there were some
ultra soft modes
as well that describe
radiation between the jets.
And then there can be also
some lambda QCD modes,
and we'll talk about
them a bit today too.
So there's a lot of different
things going on here,
but we'll see that actually
we can understand everything
and organize things using SCET.
So what's the picture
for these modes?
We have back-to-back jets.
Let me draw one jet this
way, one jet this way.
I should use some color.
So there's one of our jets.
There's another, and then
there can be soft radiation.
And between these
jets, there can also
be soft radiation
physically within the jets,
but there's no
directional dependence
to the soft radiation.
And then set that this is blue.
This and this so far are
orange in my picture.
This is green, and then
there's some hard interactions,
which we've already
sort of localized
into a dot in this picture.
So what we're doing
is we're colliding
e plus e minus producing
a virtual photon or z
and then from that
producing, if you like,
a state which is full of
collinear modes, state which
is full of the other
type of collinear
modes and ultra soft particles.
And this is in the
center of mass frame,
or that's kind of how you
could think about it in SCET,
or physically what
you're producing
is you're producing jet 1
plus jet 2 plus soft radiation
or ultra soft
hadrons, soft hadrons.
OK, so the first scale that
you want to think about
is the hard scale,
and so that is just
the q squared to the
virtual photon or z.
So if you think about
the Feynman diagram,
there's e plus e minus.
Here's q mu.
You're going to have
a pair of quarks
that that virtual
particle can couple to,
and there could be
additional gluons.
But the hard scale is set
by the virtual photon or z.
So there's going to be
some scale associated
to that hard scale q.
If you want to think about
it as a normalization scale,
there'll be some
scale where we want
to match from QCD
onto SCET, and that's
going to be the hard scale.
So I'll call that scale mu h.
So then something physical
has to set these other scales
in the picture,
and the next thing
that we need to talk about is
what we're going to measure.
In principle, if you
collide e plus e minus
and you produce hadrons,
you could have lots
of different possibilities.
In particular, you could
have not dijets but trijets,
so you could have a third
jet and made it from a gluon.
And some kind of measurement
that we do on the final state
is going to restrict us to this
configuration with just two
jets.
And the one we'll
talk about to start
is what's called hemisphere
invariant masses, which
we already mentioned earlier.
So the way that you
should think about this
is you take all the
final state particles,
and you could just take the
sum of all their momenta
and divide it into two parts,
those that are in hemisphere A
and those that are
in hemisphere B.
So let me augment my
figure here by saying
that there's two hemispheres.
And then what these masses
are, which I'll call m
squared and then
bar squared are just
the four vectors squared for
p, for the a, and the b guy.
So written in terms of
the individual particles
in that hemisphere, you
sum up all their four
vectors for the particles in
that hemisphere and square it,
and then likewise for B.
And if you're measuring
these two things,
we talked about earlier
the fact that you
could specify that it
was a jet by demanding
that they're small.
So the dijets is
going to be m squared
and then bar squared
much less than q squared.
And if you had trijets, you
wouldn't-- that wouldn't be
the case because
if you had trijets,
you'd have two particle-- two
jets in this hemisphere at wide
angles, and those-- that wide
angle would produce a large q
squared, a large and
variant mass of m squared.
That's of order q squared.
But if you just
have a single jet,
then you can have
a small m squared,
so the small m squared limit is
what forces you to have dijets.
And these guys here,
it also puts us
in the kinematic situation
where we have our n collinear
modes for one jet and
n bar collinear modes
for the other jet.
So those are two of the degrees
of freedom in our picture.
So I'm reminding you of some
things we talked about before,
but it was a while ago so--
and the power counting
parameter here is m over q.
And so if you want
to say that there's
a scale in this picture
associated to the collinear
modes, then you would say
it's on a kind of jet scale,
and that's of order m.
OK, any questions so far?
So then there's the
ultra soft radiation,
which is being ultra
soft, it's uniform.
It's not collimated
in any direction.
It's the thing that gives
you the communication
between the jets.
The jets are going to decouple
from each other in the sense
that interactions directly
between the n collinear and n
bar collinear modes is all
going into the pink dot,
but there can be long distance
communication between the jets
caused by the ultra soft modes.
So, really, what I mean here
is long distance communication.
Short distance communication
can happen too.
That's what the pink dot is, but
that's, in some sense, simpler.
Long distance
communication can only
happen by this ultra
soft radiation.
And we know about how
ultra soft radiation
interacts with
energetic particles,
and in particular, what we
know is that it's eikonal.
That came out of our
Lagrangian description
of ultra soft radiation.
And that will have
implications here.
So what is this
ultra soft radiation?
It's radiation that
has energy that's
of order q lambda squared.
And so that's m squared
over q energy radiation,
and so the soft scale,
which is the next scale down
in the picture, ultra soft
scale, is m squared over q.
Often, people will--
because there's
no soft radiation in this
setup, sometimes people
will just drop the ultra
and just call it soft.
That's very common.
I'll try to always
call it ultra soft here
because we'll be drawing
some distinctions with SCET 2
examples, and in those examples,
we have soft and collinear.
In this example, we have
ultra soft and collinear,
so I'll keep trying
to call it ultra soft.
But you can see
that I've already
abbreviated it to
u soft to make it
look more and more like soft.
Anyway, but in the
literature, people
often just drop the u
completely and call it soft.
Something to be aware of.
OK, so this actually--
this radiation here,
this is kind of the
largest scale that
can show up in
the soft function,
and there's also lambda QCD.
And that's a scale
that, at least to start,
we're going to leave
in the soft function.
So if we go back to our
picture over here, that's
why I put both the ultra soft
mode side up on this hyperbola
there, which is this m
squared over q line, mu over m
squared over q line.
That's why I made it
orange, and I also
made orange this lambda QCD
because they're together.
And you can think of
it as just that there's
some modes that are capturing
this entire region, which
are the ultra soft modes.
Now there are two--
if m squared over q was
of order lambda QCD, then
those are the same thing.
So there's kind of two
possibilities here.
You could have m squared
over q of order lambda QCD,
and that means that this
scale is not non-perturbative.
And this is what's
called, for reasons
that will become apparent by the
end of lecture, the peak region
because this is actually the
region of the cross section
where there's a peak.
OK, that's why it's
called the peak region.
And in this region, you have
the following hierarchy.
You have mu h is much
greater than mu j.
Mu j is much greater
than mu s, but mu
s is of order lambda QCD.
OK, so if we take this
to always be true,
then we're in this situation.
And there is
another possibility,
and that is that there's
really a separation
between these hyperbolas that's
just as large or hierarchical
as the previous separations.
So if this thing is much
bigger than lambda QCD,
that's another
possibility, and there'll
be a region of phase
based where this is true
and a region of phase
based where this is true.
The second one is--
here, the soft, there's--
here there is perturbative
ultra soft radiation,
so you can just calculate
it order by order
in the ultra soft scale,
which is this scale, which
is perturbative because it's
much bigger than lambda QCD.
And this is what's
called the tail region.
And the analog of
this statement here
is that we have a hierarchy
between everybody.
So when we do this analysis,
what we're going to do
is we're going to do
a power expansion.
And you can say, well,
the power expansion
is just what you told
me, m squared over--
m squared much less
than q squared,
but you also have to worry
about this when you're
doing the power expansion.
So one way of thinking
about it is just exactly
as I'm writing here, and
that's how I want to advocate.
The things you're expanding
in are these assumptions.
And you can see that
in these two cases,
there's a slightly
different set up.
So usually, when you
have an effective theory,
you have to define this from
the beginning because the way
you proceed and how you
set up your theory is going
to depend on whether
you're in this situation
or this situation.
But part of this story is the
same in these two situations,
namely the first two greater
thans, much greater thans
are the same.
And so that, we can proceed
without worrying about this.
And then we can make this
distinction later on,
and that's what my
picture was advocating
for by having these guys
in the same category.
So hopefully that's clear.
OK, so if you're
in the tail region,
there's going to be
power corrections,
and these are actually the most
important power corrections
that come as powers of lambda
QCD over the soft scale
to some power.
But you're going to have
a power expansion in that.
So that's the-- if you
like in this situation
when you're in the
tail region, you
can have power corrections that
are non-perturbative by having
ratios of these
things, lambda QCD
over this over that over this.
But the biggest one are these
guys over the soft scale,
so that's the next
smallest scale.
But if you neglect
these, the leading order
cross section in this
region is perturbative.
Now you know you can have any
power here, and those exist.
What happens in
the peak region is
that thinking about those as
an expansion is no longer good.
And you have to take all
of them and treat them
as if they're order
one and for any k,
and that ends up
meaning that there's
going to be some
non-perturbative function,
like a Parton distribution
function in the sense
that it's non-perturbative,
that describes part of what's
going on here in this region.
And that, we just see
from our power counting,
and our power counting
already tells us
that that's what's
going to happen.
So we can learn a
lot just by thinking
about the scales and the problem
and thinking about the power
counting.
So you could ask about
other power corrections.
So there's a set of
power connections
where you would expand
and say mu s over mu j.
And let me label these as
kinematic because these--
the things that setting
the scale for mu s and mu
j, say in this picture
where mu s is this
and I always distinguished
lambda QCD as a separate thing,
these scales are just
perturbative scales,
and they just
correspond to if you
think about having some
function that you're
making an expansion of it.
So they come about
from expansion
of kinematic
variables basically.
So it's the m squared
much less than q squared.
So I mean, there's nothing
non-perturbative about that.
And then you could
have power corrections
that are lambda QCD over
mu, which, if you like,
are really hard
power corrections.
They're kind of a traditional
power corrections, which are
lambda QCD over the hard scale.
And the exercise that I gave
in the homework, in some sense,
is going towards figuring out
what the sort of soft function
matrix elements would be.
Part of the problem--
there's other parts to it--
but would be going
towards figuring out
what these guys actually
are and defining them, which
is not known in the literature.
And then finally, you could
have lambda QCD over mu j,
which, of course,
you could write.
You have to be a
little bit careful
because one way that
this could happen
is that you just have one
of these guys times one
of those guys.
OK, so they're not--
it's not necessarily an
independent category,
but you could still think
about these types of power
corrections as kind of
something that might show up,
either this way or maybe
somewhat maybe directly.
And anyway, that's
another category.
It turns out that kind of--
you can get it this
way, which is something
that one can deal with.
And if it happens
directly, then it actually
is down by two
powers, so these guys
are kind of less important.
OK, so people deal with
these guys in the literature.
These guys haven't really
been fully treated yet.
Not very much is
known about them,
and this is fully treated
in the literature.
These ones that I said are
the most important ones.
OK, so even-- we can
already even outline
kind of what people are
doing because we just
think about higher order
terms of expansion,
and this is an example,
unlike B to C decays,
where we have people
going to four orders
down in the expansion.
Here even the first non-trivial
order down hasn't really been
done--
hasn't been done at all.
In the second, place
various expansions,
so it's more complicated.
And some of them have been
treated, but this one hasn't.
And I should say that the
way that this one is treated
is really just
perturbatively so it's not--
this one, in some sense,
is also not treated
fully in the language
of the effective theory.
It's just put in by hand.
So in some sense, the only
one that's treated properly
is the top one.
OK, well, we're going to
work mostly to leading order,
and we're going to call
these guys power corrections
and work with this stuff.
OK, so start with the
full theory current.
I'm not going to
distinguish too much
between pieces that come from
charges, like the electrically
charged and stuff like that.
That's not going to be
our main focus here.
We can keep track of all that.
Our main focus is going to
be understanding the QCD
effects for the jets.
So we've already done this.
The current that
has a psi bar psi
gets matched in
SCET onto something
with two Wilson lines.
There's the label.
There's another
label, and we can also
make a field redefinition.
And let me not put
zeros on the field
after the field redefinition
because that makes
it notationally cumbersome.
So this goes to this after
making that field redefinition.
OK, so this is something
we talked about earlier,
and the Wilson lines here
are capturing diagrams,
as I said earlier,
where you could have,
say, two n collinear
is one n bar,
and then this guy is off shell.
So that goes into a Wilson line
once you match it on to the--
so this is the
[? fall ?] theory.
Once you match it on to
the effective theory,
you get various extra gluons
coming out of your operator,
which is coming from
these Wilson lines,
and it's because
you're integrating off
shell particles.
So if you just look
at the kinematics,
then there's already
actually some fairly powerful
restrictions.
We're in the center
of mass frame.
Momentum conservation
says that if we
think about all particles in
the final stages either being
n collinear or n bar
collinear for ultra soft,
then the initial momentum of
the virtual photon or virtual C
has to add up to all
the final stage momenta.
And if we just look at
the large part of that,
in the center of mass frame,
n bar dot q is just capital Q,
and that's n bar dot pxn
plus things that are small.
And likewise, n dot q
equals capital q equals
n dot pxn bar, which is
large order one plus small.
So these guys here are lowest--
leading order in
the power counting,
and these guys are suppressed.
And what happens is
like in the example
we talked about when we
were doing [? bs ?] gamma.
We have these labels,
omega and omega
bar on our collinear
fields up there.
They just get fixed to the
qs by momentum conservation.
So I said this was
generically going
to happen whenever we had
operators that had only one
type of building block
in each collinear sector,
and that's exactly
the situation we have.
Some momentum conservation
is strong enough
to fix that omega is equal
to q and so is omega bar.
So the first thing I
want to do is show you
how to factorize to the
cross section in this case.
So what would you do in
QCD for this cross section?
Well, you'd say
the cross section
is a sum over some restricted
set of final states
that satisfy the kinematic
criteria that I'm
interested in.
You'd have a momentum
conserving delta function,
and you could write it
as sort of leptonic or--
yeah, leptonic tensor, and
then kind of a hadronic tensor,
the same way we
do for [? DIS. ?]
So you would start-- could
start with that formula, which
is really true for anything
that you might want to measure,
which is just imposed by kind
of what states you include here.
And I haven't yet
specified exactly what
I'm going to measure.
We'll still have to put that in.
So part of what SCET does
is make these restrictions
into something that
shows up in the operators
rather than showing
up in the states.
And ideally, we'd like to
sort of get rid of the states
eventually and be
able to calculate--
see how to calculate things.
So in SCET, once we know that
we're in a dijet configuration,
we can think of
the state as having
been composed of sort of pieces
for the different sectors.
And we know that this is an OK
picture because our Lagrangian
for these guys factored.
And when the Lagrangian
factors, that
means the Hamiltonian factors
and the Hilbert space factors
after the field redefinition.
OK, so we can put in our
expansion of the current
at the top of the
board over there,
and then put it into this
formula, and see what we get.
And there's some pre-factors.
I'm now summing over
just these states.
There are still some
restrictions depending
on what I'm measuring, but they
are different restrictions,
and they're simpler.
There's still momentum
conserving delta function,
but I can write it out as
pxn pxn bar px ultra soft.
And because of
the states factor,
I can factor also with a little
bit of work the operators.
So I can write the operators.
I'll just write it down.
I think it's clear.
And I'll tell you
some of the things
you have to do to get there.
So I am skipping some steps
here because if we do it--
we can do it very carefully,
and we come write out each step
one at a time.
But there's a lot of
writing if one does that,
so I'm kind of
trying to write steps
where I think it's intuitive
what the results are
and skip steps
that some level can
be filled in either by
looking at the literature
or you just believe me.
So we have these operators
that were still tied together
in some sense because there
is a color contraction
of an index between them.
But we can get around that
basically using some--
once we realized that the matrix
elements factor like this,
we can use some color identities
and put it in this form.
So there's an
overall pre-factor 1
over nc, which I didn't write.
There's some
overall pre-factors,
but the color is separate.
There's a trace, if you
like, over color here,
and these guys here are traced
into color singlets as well.
Ray trace in each case.
So just using some color
identities, we can do that.
So once-- remember the
fact that the states factor
in that the operators can
be written in a product
means that all contractions are
happening between these guys
and these guys.
That's why I can separate the
matrix elements the way I have.
And the only thing
is then that there
could be color indices
tying these guys together,
but it turns out you could
deal with that as well.
When you deal with
the color theories,
you could get things like--
you could get a ta in here or--
well, you could get, for
example, ta ta or something,
but then there's
some ways of getting
rid of those terms related to
the fact that this has to be--
you have to argue that certain
things are color singlets.
I'm not going to
go through that.
So there's terms that
we're dropping here,
and those are the
other high order--
those are the other
power corrections.
So this keeps all the power
corrections of the first type,
mu s, lambda QCD over mu
s because those can still
be encoded in our
soft function, which
is going to be this thing
involving the soft states.
But it drops the other
power corrections.
AUDIENCE: How do you
know that since you
derived the
[INAUDIBLE] by looking
at the perturbative diagrams?
PROFESSOR: No, I didn't.
I can derive--
I don't need to look at
perturbative diagrams
to draw the Wilson lines.
I just derived them
from the SCET Lagrangian
by making the
field redefinition.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
that because the Langrangian
decoupled, that's good for all--
PROFESSOR: All soft particles.
So far, we actually
haven't needed
to use perturbation
theory, and the idea here
is that we're not going to
use perturbation theory.
We're going to write
down some formula that's
true to all orders in
perturbation theory,
and we're really only
trading the power expansion.
That's what we're
focusing on here
without thinking about things
as perturbative things.
Although, obviously,
some of these functions
will be perturbative
functions that we
will end up wanting to compute.
OK, so let's think about
what res prime means.
And it's really a reminder
that this formula is only
really valid if we're
making a measurement
on the final state that really
puts us in this configuration.
So it's not enough to say
we are in this situation.
You're going to have to measure
something that makes you
in that dijet configuration, and
that's important to remember.
And so we're going to measure
the hemisphere invariant
masses.
So we need to cook
that into our formula,
and there's a very
easy way of doing that.
We say that the
following is true.
I can write one, which is
equal to an integral of two
delta functions.
And this formula
is obviously true.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to instead of
integrating this,
I'm going to move it as
a d sigma d these things,
and that's going to leave
these delta functions
inside the formula here.
But since they depend on
collinear and soft momenta,
which are the momenta
that are in these states,
they're going to be sort
of tightly connected
to the whole thing, whatever
is going on in this formula.
It's not like they
commute with this xn.
They only commute
with the xn if I
can make them into the identity
by integrating over this.
But once I pull this
through and put it over
on the right hand side--
left hand side, then you have
to leave these delta functions
there.
They're specifying
the measurement.
So this is a total n
collinear momentum,
and this is the total
ultra soft in hemisphere A.
That's what the A means.
So I divided everything into
hemisphere A and B. Obviously,
all the n collinear
particles, which
are going in that direction,
are in that hemisphere,
but the soft ones could
go in either case.
And so then there's a soft
momentum in hemisphere B
and soft momentum in hemisphere
A. Now this is unexpanded.
I can also expand
these delta functions,
and I only need to keep the
leading order piece if we're
working at leading order.
And so the leading order
pieces are as follows.
There's an order of
lambda squared piece.
This is lambda squared.
There's an order of
lambda squared piece
from the collinear
momentum squared,
and since this is a
total collinear momentum,
it can involve multiple
massless particles.
It doesn't have to be zero.
And then there's a cross
term between the softs
and the collinear.
It's also order lambda squared.
This order one.
And this is order
lambda squared,
and that term's the same size.
And then all the other
terms are higher order.
These terms are suppressed,
so this is really
all I need to keep.
There's also something
else that effectively we've
done by setting things up,
and that is, in general, you
could think that the collinear
particles would have some perp
momentum.
But we aligned our
axes with the jet axis,
so there's actually no
perp momentum there either.
So that guy is really just--
we can pull out a pn minus and
then we have pn plus k sa plus.
And we also know
that pn minus is q.
That was fixed by kinematics.
OK, so this simplifies
quite a bit.
And we're going to drop all the
powers of [INAUDIBLE] terms.
All right, so that is one thing.
So then I can do what I said
in words, write this guy,
and it will have
these two deltas that
are under similar acts.
They don't commute through
with it-- without it.
They depend on x.
Now another thing
we would like to do
is the factorize
the measurement.
So this measurement
here involves
the sum of a plus momentum
collinear and a plus momentum
in soft.
And it's all in
one delta function.
We'd like to write it as
separate delta functions
that we can associate with
those different parts here,
one delta-- we'd like to
have a separate thing here
from these guys.
And that's actually
very easy to do.
We simply write the following.
Just introduce some
more delta functions.
So there's this tying
together delta function.
K plus is just some
dummy variable.
It's not the momentum
of any state.
It's just a dummy variable,
whereas pn plus and ksa plus
were momenta of
particles in the state.
So this guy can then
associate with the--
put them together with the
n collinear matrix element,
which is this guy here.
I forget what color he was.
And then for the
ultra soft, we can
associated this delta function.
So that's what I
mean by factoring
the measurement, that
we can put the piece,
depended on the state, together.
And then you can see
that we can move our--
well, OK, we have to also
factor this delta function.
I should say that too.
That's the part that I'm
not going to go through,
but we can play similar
games expanding and factoring
this delta four as well.
And that's besides just
being a little bit tedious,
it's not really any
more difficult. Maybe
a little more difficult.
So we factor that guy too.
And then there's one other
trick that we want to do,
which is useful, and
that is that we can write
some deltas in Fourier's space.
So we can always
write a delta function
as an integral over a
phase, and that's convenient
because in the phase,
the momenta that
are in the delta
function also factor.
So I can write it as a product
of two separate factors
like this.
There's some halves.
It's conventional.
OK, so this guy here,
which is the guy that
is associated to
the state, it looks
like a translation operator.
if you have an e to the i
x dot p, that you can use.
You can put into
your matrix element,
and you can translate
the fields, which
are in this formula all at 0.
They're all at space time 0.
What you can do
with this guy here
is you can put it into
the matrix element
and translate the
fields to point x.
And then you'd have
a chi and x minus.
So that's how we can
deal with that guy.
And so if we do a bunch
of stuff like that I'm not
going to go through on the
board for you, after some work,
we get something just kind
of an intermediate step
of our factorization,
which I'll write out
so you can get some idea of--
if I jump to the final answer,
it's kind of too simple
to see what's going on.
So let's write this one out.
So I was focusing on the n
collinear matrix element,
and everything I was writing,
I wrote this delta function.
But there's, of course, another
one for the delta n bar,
and I do the same thing for him.
So we got k plus and l plus
by factoring the measurement
there.
You get a k minus and
an l minus by factoring
the other measurement.
One thing that comes into--
that makes this guy here
a little more complicated
is you have to think a little
bit about residual and label
momentum.
But at the end of the day, the
result is what I'm writing.
So this is going to be
completely factorizing to three
independent things.
There's one set of collinear
fields for the quark,
and there's another for
the antiquark if you like.
You're specifying
whether it's a quark
or an antiquark with a label.
So the fact that this
label here is positive
means that this is a quark, and
maybe this should be a minus q.
And then this guy is
specifying the antiquark,
and then there's the soft part.
OK, so this is a fairly
messy one board expression,
but this guy here is factored.
We have the hard modes
here, collinear modes,
n collinear here, and
bar collinear there,
and the ultra soft goes
here, which I've already
dropped in my ultra soft.
So this last guy if you think
about what this matrix element
is it's just some function.
We sum over all x of this.
So we sum over all the
intermediate states.
The only thing we're fixing
are l plus and l minus.
So when we sum over
states, we actually
integrate the momentum
of particles in the state
if you can think of that.
Those are different states.
You have to sum over them too,
but it's a continuous label
and therefore you integrate
over the phase base.
And that's what we mean when
we write the sum over axis.
That includes phase
based intervals.
And so the only--
so this momentum
gets integrated
over if you like,
but then it gets--
there's a component that
gets fixed, which is the total
momentum of plus or minus
momentum in each hemisphere.
So this is just some function.
So that we color the same.
It's just some function
of l plus or l minus,
and it's called a soft function.
And at this stage
of the game, it's
actually encoding two
different momentum scales.
The l plus and minus
as well as sort
of lambda QCD, which I
didn't write explicitly
as an argument.
And l plus and
minus, well, we'll
see later, but you can
think of l plus and minus
roughly as encoding the scale
that's m squared over q.
This will become more
clear in a minute.
So again, we need to figure
out what these guys here are.
That's a little bit more
work but not too much.
And they're both, of course,
mirrors of each other.
So really, we just have to be
one of them, and if you like,
the other is just kind
of charge congregation.
So this guy here, we're going
to write in Fourier's space.
That's a convenient
thing to do because what
we know about the Feynman
rules in Fourier's space
when we thought about
the Feynman rules
in Fourier's space, we knew that
the collinear propagators would
only depend on the
small plus momentum.
So the x-coordinates
here, the x-coordinates
of our fields,
those corresponded
to residual momenta, but
when we do Feynman diagrams,
there's only the plus
momentum showing up.
That's the multipole expansion.
So you could think about it
from the [? phonographs, ?]
but it's really a
general property
from the multipole expansion.
So that means that some of these
integrals here are just trivial
and give me a delta function.
So I'm getting delta functions
in some directions because
of the multipole
expansion in this formula.
Because I aligned
the axis, there
was no perpendicular momentum,
so it's really just this r plus
that we get, and this thing
here is called the jet function.
So this is the non-trivial
function that can show up.
We do the same thing.
We do the same thing for the
case with the sum over xn bar,
and it gives us
another jet function.
And by charge conjugation,
it's the same jet function.
But in this case, it would
be q of sum r prime minus
and some other momentum.
And so what we then do
is we take this formula,
plug it back into here, do all
the integrals, and at the end
of the day, we can actually do--
we have lots of delta functions
and lots of integrals.
And we can boil everything
down to just two integrals left
over.
And that gives us our final
result. So I'll write this way.
So it boils down
to just involving
these jet functions
and the soft function,
and then there's
something that's
called the hard function, which
is just our Wilson coefficient
squared.
So rather than write
Wilson coefficient
squared all the time, we just
call it another function h.
So this is the
factorization theorem.
So you see in this case,
the hard function was just
a multiplicative
factor unlike dis,
and what was-- where things
are talking to each other.
Again, things are
talking to each other,
but it's the soft modes--
ultra soft modes that
are talking to the jets.
And ultra soft momenta
can change the mass,
and that's what kind
of the correct mass--
this is the total mass.
The correct mass for the jet
function is the collinear mass,
and that's this thing
minus this thing.
So if you wanted to guess this
formula, this is how you do it.
You'd say m squared, just
from the kinematic relation,
m squared had a collinear
piece and a soft piece.
The right thing to evaluate
the jet function at
would be just the collinear,
so that's the difference.
And then the soft function
could depend on these momentum,
and you're basically led
to a formula like this one.
But we can also just,
with the field theory,
go through and
derive it, and that's
what I'm convincing you of even
if I was skipping some steps.
All right, so this is the
dijet factorization theorem
for hemisphere invariant masses.
And a lot of event
shapes kind of
go along the pattern
that we've done here.
If you think about what would
be the difference if I pick
some other observable both
sides of these masses,
pick some other thing that you
could measure that would tell
you that there's dijets, we just
swap out the measurement part,
and that would lead to-- and
just see where it leads us.
A lot of the steps would
be exactly the same steps.
So we did it for one
particular observable,
but steps are the
same if you do others.
If you're in this situation
where you have dijets,
there's more than one
way of measuring an event
to ensure you have dijets.
There's something called
dijet event shapes.
They go under the names
of things like thrust,
C parameter, heavy jet mass.
All these things actually
have factorization theorems
that you could derive in a
similar way to what we're
doing here.
All right, now this
is kind of like--
I didn't put any
mus in, but just
like we did before, we
can always put the mus in.
So if we put the mus
in, everybody gets a mu.
The h is like the mu of
the Wilson coefficient,
and then the Js are like--
and Ss are like mus of--
from the point of
view of SCET, they're
like mus of the operator.
We're just switching to
renormalized operators
and renormalized
Wilson coefficients.
Now if we draw our
scale diagram again
but draw it a little
bigger this time
and put in where these
various functions are--
so somebody was blue.
Not going to label
everybody again.
So this is the hard function.
Our jet functions are kind
of sitting at this scale.
They had to do with
the collinear modes,
and then our soft function is
sitting at this scale or this
and this scale.
So it's clear that these
things sit at different scales.
And what that means from the
point of view of the formula
is that if you associate
what scale these things want
to live at, which from the point
of view of perturbation theory
means at what scale
should I expect-- would I
be able to calculate
these things given
that they're perturbative?
Would I be able to
calculate these things
without encountering
large logarithms?
And that would be these
scales that I'm writing here.
So these are the
scales where we could
do perturbative theory
for the functions
without encountering
large logarithms.
So we can figure out
what these skills
are by just looking at
the perturbative theory
and looking at the logarithms.
But you see that it's a
different scale for each
of the different functions.
So in this formula,
there's a common mu, which
is like a factorization scale.
But each of the functions wants
to live at a different mu,
and we're going to have to
do some renormalization group
evolution to put things at
kind of at the scales they
want to be at.
And then there'll be some
resummation going on,
and that's going to sum logs
of m squared over q squared.
So we need normalization
group, and that's
trying to sum up
logarithms, which
are ratios of
these scales, which
expressed in terms of
some physical thing
is, in this case, logs of
m squared over q squared.
All right, what about
this situation here?
Well, it turns out--
and I won't go into
it in too much detail,
but we can factor that guy.
If these two are
hierarchical, we
can actually factor
this in something called
the soft function OPE, and even
if they're not hierarchical,
we can actually write
it in the following way.
So we can always, in some
sense, whether or not
we're in a situation
where these are comparable
or whether they're
hierarchical, we can always
use the following formula.
We're not guaranteed
that that is possible,
but in this situation, it
is possible to sort of make
those two situations
compatible with each other
with a single formula.
Usually, when you design
effective theories,
you kind of for each
different expansion,
you have a different
result. And making them--
whether you can put them
together into a single result
is not always guaranteed.
But this is a situation where
we can put things together
in a single result
where these are
the perturbative part
of the soft function,
and this is the non-perturbative
lambda QCD effects.
If you imagine that the
function-- if you imagine
that these two axes
are hierarchical,
then this perturbative guy here
gives you some ls corrections,
and it basically, in
terms of the l plus,
in terms of the momentum
variable in this formula,
it's giving something that's,
like, a power-- what's called
the power law tail.
So the kind of dependence
that you're getting in
is some logs over an
l plus, and that's
called a power law since
it goes like 1 over l plus,
whereas these effects here
that are non-perturbative
live down at
non-perturbative momenta,
and you can actually prove that
they have an exponential tail.
So this is some plot of f in
a one dimensional projection,
so let's just
think of it as one.
And this is some scale
of order lambda QCD.
So at some blob down
lambda QCD, this
describing the distribution
of soft hadrons,
and it's non-perturbative.
It's not like I'm drawing
it because I know it.
So it looks something like
this, whereas this part, we
can calculate and it has
a different dependence.
This is a power law.
This is an exponential.
OK, so that's kind of
further factorization
of the s and to get rid to
make those two axis separated.
Can separate the
perturbative and
non-perturbative corrections.
In some sense, if
you're in a situation
where they're comparable,
then whether you
take a non-perturbative
function and if l plus is small
and you integrated
against this, you're
just getting back some other
non-perturbative function.
So this formula is not really--
there are some things that this
formula is actually doing, even
in that situation, is ensuring
that you're in the ms bar
scheme for example.
But the sort of more
important in some ways
is when they're
hierarchical, and then you
can start to expand
this thing and--
because in that case,
this l plus prime
would be localized down here,
and the l plus-- if the l plus
got big, then you can start
doing a Taylor series,
and this formula would
tell you what the-- how
to put the corrections together.
So there's kind of a lot
of physics in that formula
that I'm not going
into in detail.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I don't
really totally understand
why this is valid.
Are you allowed to-- does the
soft function code all those
below that hyperbola?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is that--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Below the above one and--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, below the s.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
The soft function.
You should always
think of these things
as kind of extending down to the
axes in some kind of fashion.
So let's drop like this.
Since they're infrared modes
and the infrared is sort of
down at the axis, you
should always think of them
as extending down to the axis.
Now exactly how you want to
think about how the soft modes
and whether the soft modes
are capturing the entire axis
or the collinear--
how the collinear
modes and the soft mouths
kind of what the edges are
is related to the
power counting.
And you can think of
the collinear modes
as kind of being held
away from the axis
because the soft modes are
really deeper in the infrared.
AUDIENCE: But at higher power,
are you going to screw these up
if you say-- like suppose the
soft modes have an invariant
mass of lambda to the
fifth, right, or they're--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
No, that's-- you never
have to worry about--
you could worry about putting
in more hyperbolas, right,
with lambda QCD
over q or something.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And you
don't have to do that.
AUDIENCE: OK, so--
PROFESSOR: You never
have to do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Why is that?
PROFESSOR: I mean, essentially,
that's because those--
any lambda QCDs,
what this x means
is that lambda QCD is encoded
in the soft-- in this kind
of non-perturbative soft mode.
And if you had something that at
higher powers like lambda QCD,
to take your example,
to the sixth,
the one over q to the
sixth is going to come out
in some coefficient.
And the lambda QCD
to the sixth is just
going to be some matrix
element of this mode that
has that dimension.
That's how it's going to work.
So in some sense,
you could say, well,
what if I put a mode down there?
And I would just say, well,
that mode's inside this mode.
You don't have to write down
something different for that.
It's all encoded in the
Lagrangian for that mode,
and that mode has all the
non-perturbative physics.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
at a higher power,
I would think you're comparing--
PROFESSOR: So this is--
AUDIENCE: --two powers by--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this
is a good question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] actually
significantly much smaller.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so one way of
thinking about it is like this.
When you design the
effective theory,
you actually have to figure
out what the degrees of freedom
are at lowest order.
And when you go to
higher order, you
shouldn't be having new degrees
of freedom popping up at you.
Yeah, and so that's kind
of at the heart of what
I'm saying here.
That's a kind of an even
deeper way of saying it
because what you're doing with
the power connections is you're
kind of figuring out how to
put factors in the numerator
if you want to think
in Feynman diagrams.
You're not changing
the propagators.
You've already figured
out the propagators
with your leading order theory.
So you have sort of where
all the poles can occur,
and now you're just sort of
doing perturbation theory.
Perturbation theory
shouldn't introduce
new degrees of freedom in the--
when you're expanding
in the power expansion.
All right, so to
draw a picture, I
want to tell you about one other
observable, which is thrust.
So thrust can be
defined by this formula
here in general,
which is that you
find some axis,
which is actually
an axis that's going to--
in our dijet configuration
in the jet axis.
You find the axis that
maximizes this thing,
and in the case of a
dijet configuration,
that's going to align
with the jet axis.
And then you do this sum, and
that calculate some variable t.
T turns out to have kinematic
limits between a half and one,
and if you want to talk
about something that's
a little more convenient,
you define something
called tau, which is 1 minus t.
And the dijet limit
of tau is zero.
That's why this is more.
So the dijet limit
of t is the limit
where you just have kind of
two pencil-like back-to-back
things.
In that case, this goes to one.
And if you wanted to find
something that goes to zero,
then you define it as tau.
Just a little more convenient.
And so it's possible to
work out that when you're
in a dijet configuration
that tau with a bit of work
you can show it's actually
simply the sum of our two
hemisphere invariant masses.
So obviously, in a
dijet configuration,
there's lots of simplifications
to the kinematics.
And with some work, one
can show that that's true.
So what this is an
observable, which is simply
a symmetric projection of
our previous two variable
observable onto one
variable observable.
But if we demand that,
for example, tau is small,
that's demanding both m
squared and n bar squared
are small because they're
positive quantities,
and we're just summing.
So demanding that this is
small is demanding both
of those variables is small.
So tau much less than one also
is a way of getting dijets,
and that's a way of
getting dijets just
with one variable
rather than two.
So that's, of course,
easier to draw a picture
with one thing rather than two.
So if we take our formula
for the two variables
and we project onto one,
then we can do that.
It looks like this.
So what happens to the
jet-- the two jet functions
and the soft function
that had two variables
is that they get
projected kind of
on to their symmetric
projection of the two variables.
So this is like--
these two are
symmetric projections.
So we had two variables before,
and now we have one variable.
And it's a symmetric
projection, and that just
follows from this formula.
So literally, to
get this result,
we would just do the
same trick we did before.
We'd say that this is true.
Now let's move the
integral d m squared
and d n bar squared
onto the right hand side
and think about doing
those integrals.
And we follow through,
and it would lead
to a formula like this one.
AUDIENCE: J tau is j squared?
PROFESSOR: J tau is j squared.
J tau is literally
j j integrated
over so fixing kind
some of the momentum
and integrating
over the difference.
So this guy depends
on one momentum,
and this guy-- these guys depend
on 2, and there's one integral.
And then s tau is
like one integral
of kind of something like this.
So let's call the
integral l prime.
It's kind of like that.
So that's what I mean by
asymmetric projection.
AUDIENCE: And so how
do you know that tau
can be written as
a function n bar,
or could another kinematic
variable [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: No, it can be
written as a function of n bar.
Yeah, because you're still--
if you're in subleading power,
as long as you're in the
dijet's configuration,
we've got the right
degrees of freedom.
We don't need another
jet degree of freedom.
So if you want to describe--
you could think about
the thrust distribution.
Well, let me answer your
question in more detail.
Let me tell you
where you would have
to worry about more
degrees of freedom,
but let me do it in a second.
I'll give you-- all right,
so in the thrust case
and what we said about
masses carries over
to a formula like this,
where this mu h squared
being much bigger than
mu j squared, much bigger
than mu s squared.
And then that could be much
greater than or of order lambda
QCD squared.
And the type of terms that our
factorization theorem would
be able to resum if we did the
renormalization group evolution
would be sums of powers
of alpha and logs of tau.
Tau is dimensionless
variable, and so the kind
of terms that would show
up in the cross section
are terms like that plus
non-perturbative effects.
So if you want to think
the base level, what
is inside our formula,
it's all these terms.
We're able to determine them
from our factorization theorem,
and then there's also
some non-perturbative,
which would be kind of-- and
non-perturbative effects that
in this f function.
And the factorization
theorem is telling us
how to compute these
things and include them.
So what does it look
like as a picture?
What does the
cross-section look like?
So there's a peak as I
promised, and there's kind of--
and then there's a tail.
And so this is tau.
This is d sigma d tau.
You can always normalize.
This peak is
happening in the kind
of non-perturbative region.
So because it's a
symmetric projection,
there's a factor
of two, but it's
kind of basically happening
when taus of order lambda
QCD over q.
And we could figure out
that just by power counting.
And then depending
on the value of cue,
that sort of for a
typical configuration, tau
equals 0.1 would
be over somewhere
over there, et cetera.
So this is the peak, aptly named
because it looks like a peak.
And in this peak, there's
non-perturbative effects
that come from the f.
This is the tail.
It could be called
the shoulder, but it's
kind of once you're
out here and down here,
this is what you
call the tail where
you have a perturbative s tau.
And then you would include
power corrections by expanding.
And the expansion would give you
lambda QCD over the soft scale,
which is q tau.
So this is-- that's that
expansion that we talked about,
and that comes
from expanding it,
f, or an expansion
that involves f.
It's not expanding f.
Basically, what
these numerators are
are moments of f once
you do the expansion.
And then there's
a region out here,
and in both of these
regions, you have dijets.
But in this region out here,
you don't have dijets anymore.
That's where tau is
starting to get large
and you no longer have dijets.
So if you wanted to think
about sort of higher order
corrections in the
distribution out here,
then you would need to
perhaps think about three jets
and other things.
In particular, there's
also a kind of shoulder
here that if you
really want to think
about how power corrections
are kind of properly
dealing with that region, you
think about more than two jets.
But if you just kind of restrict
yourself to here and here,
which is all we're going to
do, then you don't-- then every
mode, even if you go
to subleading order,
is exactly the ones
that we just said.
And you just have to deal with
them by constructing operators
in subleading order.
So that's the more detailed
answer to your question.
Any other questions?
OK, so I'll say a few things
about the perturbation theory.
So so far we've kind
of argued that we
could get pretty far without
doing perturbation theory.
So we got here without
What if we actually now want
to calculate these series,
do the normalization
group evolution?
How's that going to work?
And it's actually--
in some ways,
it's a combination of the
two examples that we treated.
We did an example where we
had a Wilson coefficient that
was just running
multiplicatively,
and we did another
example where we
had a function for deep
and elastic scattering.
It had an integral,
and we're going
to have both of those
situations in this case.
So let me tell you how it works.
So to get the hard function,
you would do some matching,
and the matching is actually for
what people call the quark form
factor.
So if you wonder why people care
about the quark form factor,
the quark form
factor is basically
the h in our
formula, not exactly,
but closely related to
the h in our formula.
So you would do some one loop
matching by taking QCD graphs
and subtracting the SCET graphs
in exactly the kind of way
we were already doing
for the examples
that we treated before.
So those are collinear gluons.
This is an ultra soft gluon.
And there's some wave function
graphs that you can consider.
We form the difference.
And at one loop, we check
that all the IR divergences
between this and this
cancel, and then we
get the Wilson coefficient.
So this is very, very
analogous to the example
that we did when we were
doing a heavy light current.
And you see here that this
thing, which depends on mu,
it's mu over q.
And that's what I was
saying that the Wilson
coefficient or the hard
function should be--
the log should be minimized
from mu of order q.
And we see that by
doing the calculation.
H is the square of this thing.
So there's imaginary parts
on these negative logarithms.
These are minus q
squared minus i 0.
But when I take the mod
square, this thing is real.
What about the jet function?
Well, if you go back to what
the formula for the jet function
was, the jet
function is basically
two fields like spit out a
quark and absorb a quark.
But it's a vacuum
matrix element,
so the quarks are
just contracted.
So you're basically
calculating graphs
like this or, really, actually
the imaginary parts of graphs
like this because
the way I drew it,
you were summing
over final states,
so it would be the
imaginary part.
So we could just calculate the
graphs without putting a cut in
and take the imaginary part,
and that would actually
be giving us the jet function.
So the jet function comes
from some Feynman diagrams
that look like this.
And then there's one
more looks like that.
So at one move, we have
those three Feynman diagrams.
And then we have the
[INAUDIBLE] little guy.
We take the imaginary part.
We get the jet function.
At lowest order, it
gives a delta function
just to cut propagator.
And then at one [INAUDIBLE],,
you get a delta function,
and you also get plus functions.
That may not worry so much
about what the numbers are.
I can just tell you what
the result looks like.
It looks like that.
There's three different types
of terms that we could get.
They all kind of have
a power counting that
makes them go like one over s.
And that you know ahead of time.
If you power count
the operator here,
it should scale one over s.
These are the different
kind of structures
that you can get at one
loop that scale one over s.
And this is kind of
a symptom of there
being 1 over epsilon
squared divergences,
and this guy here
are [INAUDIBLE]
the renormalized results.
So we're taking care
of the renormalization.
So just like in our example--
I mean, it's the
same diagram really.
Just this diagram was
familiar because this diagram
was showing up in
beta s gamma, right?
So we saw it had 1 over
epsilon squared poles.
Here, the 1 over epsilon
squared poles lead to this.
And, really, you
can actually think
of that very closely
related to what
we did because we were finding
logs of mu squared over p
squared, but here, p
squared is a physical thing.
It's the s, the invariant mass
that we pump into the operator.
S is kind of what we
put in through the--
we put in a momentum,
if you like, q, where--
I shouldn't call it q--
t mu where s is
t squared, right?
And so before we were having
logs of p squared, which
were an IR regulator, but in
this calculation for this jet
function, it's actually
a physical thing.
And it's giving the momentum
dependents of the jet function,
but it's the right thing to
stick into the factorization
theorem.
And then there's
the soft function
where if it's perturbative,
you can calculate it.
And you can draw these kind of
in some notation for the Wilson
lines.
So here's our Wilson lines
in different directions.
And then want this
matrix element squared,
and, again, you
can sort of think
of as kind of cut graphs
like that if you like.
And if we look at
the soft function,
it kind of has a similar
structure to the jet function
but now with the--
so, again, it's got a
delta function and then
plus functions.
Whoops.
And it turns out there's
no single plus function,
but there is a plus function
with a logarithm in this case.
And then same for l minus.
Same structure.
It's just a product if you like.
And the reason that happens
is if you only have one gluon,
it's either in hemisphere
A or hemisphere
B. It can't be in both.
So the alpha s corrections are
either a function of l plus
or a function of l
minus, and that's
why it has a kind of very
simple structure at one loop.
So that gives you
an idea of what
these perturbative
functions look like.
C, if you talk about
renormalization,
C renormalizes multiplicatively.
And so the renormalization
group equation for C
is just like the one we had
before for beta s gamma.
There's no integrals.
That, again, came about
from the kinematics
fixing the variables.
But the jet function
and the soft function
have convolutions in this case.
Well, they depend on this
non-trivial momentum,
and it's--
you can see in the factorization
theorem, that is convoluting
between two different sectors.
And it kind of
generically a hint
that you're going to get out
a formula like this one, which
is like the PDF, but now
it's a different formula.
It was kind of an almost
dimension for the jet function.
So we could go through
that, but I was not
writing down for you what the
1 over epsilons look like.
But we could go through
the renormalization
and find these results.
And actually, in this
jet function case,
we even know more.
The general structure of
this anomalous dimension
is actually simpler than the
Parton distribution case.
And it's the following.
There's two types of
terms that can show up.
So the general structure
of the anomalous dimension
is that there's a
single plus function
in it or a delta function.
And this single plus
function is the analog
in the jet function of
the single logarithm that
was showing up.
Remember that when we
decompose this guy,
there could be a
log mu over q term
or a one term with
no log of mu over q.
This is like an analog of
a log, this plus function.
If you integrate
over s, then it's
like ds over s,
which is like a log.
So this is a log, and
integrating delta of s
is like one.
So the analog
statement that there
was two possibilities there.
In this case, there's
an analog of that,
and there's two
possibilities here.
And what perturbation
theory is doing
is actually just computing
the coefficients of these two
different structures.
OK, and we're out of time,
so I'll say a few more words
about how you would solve,
for example, an equation
like this one.
Next time I'll tell
you how to solve it,
and then we'll basically
be done with our example.
We'll put things back together
and write down a factorization
theorem that includes
the resummation
and then we'll go on
to another example.
Moving on, the next example
we'll treat after this one
is SCET two where
we'll be dealing
with energetic hadrons,
some other types of examples
besides jets.